[Music]
now newt gingrich no one's everyone's
saying he's he's through newt gingrich
claims he still has a chance newt
gingrich said people walk up to him all
the time and beg him to stay in the race
that's what he just said yeah it's a
group of people known as democrats
i'm up here
i know you heard about
did you know that this week is the 100th
anniversary of the sinking of the
titanic yeah on sunday a cruise ship set
out from england to exactly replicate
the voyage of the titanic
yeah the tickets are most popular with
people who have no idea what happened
well this should be fun
when we get to the we don't get to new
york oh
what happens
that seems like such a weird idea to me
i mean and when they get to this the
spot what do they do at that point i
don't know turn around and go back
if they're lucky yeah
all right
if it all goes well
uh a new study just came out new study
finds that homophobia
may be linked to a subconscious
attraction to your own gender
yeah
yeah rick santorum has called the study
as hard to believe as ryan gosling's
perfect ass
[Applause]
what am i doing
it's that right look how far
apart right
i have a buttock here and a buttock
there
and everyone knows your copper feel like
this
i like this
i'm glad i don't know
now you do okay i'm i'm look at me i'm
tuning a giant radio over here
[Laughter]
inside into my dating life yes back in
the day
ow uh
it's being reported that 74 year old
morgan freeman
is planning to marry his 27 year old
step granddaughter
yeah yeah the uh the whole story sounds
a little creepy unless you hear it
narrated by morgan freeman
[Applause]
[Music]
then it's just heartwarming yeah
there are penguins in it
[Laughter]
they escape a prison uh
uh big story out of kansas in kansas the
mega millions winner who took home
157 million dollars has chosen to remain
anonymous
yeah a spokesman for the winner said his
client just wants to blend in with all
the other people in kansas who have 157.
[Applause]
yeah
my solid gold sombrero
my two white leopards
the fbi is reporting that american
universities are being infiltrated by
foreign spies
yeah yeah they say everyone should be on
the lookout for any student who's paying
attention and taking notes
[Applause]
you're proud of yourselves not kids
lindsay lohan is denying rumors that she
punched a woman in a bar this saturday
yeah no one said trust me when i hit
someone it's with my car
and then this is weird according to a
new study that just came out 23 year old
women wear the shortest skirts
yeah that's the study yeah
yeah the study was conducted by a
scientist who's had it with trying to
cure cancer
he's like i'm going out i'm measuring
skirts
that sounds like a guy who's just ready
to have some fun
all right well i got to mention this in
north korea a new a new mural of kim
jong-il was recently unveiled and i
don't know if you saw this on the news i
just saw it i'd say quite an impressive
mural take a look
[Applause]
nice